I always said Nina that that geeks would
inherit the earth and Becky is proof
once again the fattest point antiques
and women will eventually inherit the
earth so here we go mattering like he's
the first one he's fabulous she's great
comic relief seems very charming as are
you and she's afraid of everything which
everything guessing is not the case of
you I'm the opposite
yeah it was kind of ironic that I was
chosen to play this role because I am
probably the first one that when when in
a extreme situation there's an
opportunity I'll be the first one in
line and so there was a lot of acting
involved I had to play pretend and play
scared a lot fun because I was saying I
don't want to do these things as my
character but Nina was just dying to get
into the middle of the action of course
you were now that we have we have
motorbikes that can ride waves we had a
real thing where the way wasn't like
that I thought I didn't think it was
really in there but apparently that's
like a real thing that's incredible yeah
I was incredible so you have that and by
that you have skiing go through the
jungle editorial feels real but out of
all of these that you're you know you're
your task mates and the stunt people are
doing we did one of them were you most
dying to try um honestly I'm going to
throw it back to the original movie I
would have loved to snowboard down an
avalanche is coming and then like beat
all the we know the snowmobiles I know
that was about a sequence I'll bet you
ride do you write I do yeah yeah I've
been snowboarding and skiing from the
age of five to ten and then from ten til
now I've been snowboarding Oh
so if Becky sticks around and if there
are more xxx I'm guessing here or go
ahead you know my fingers Alyssa you're
going to see more action and you want
that very much so very much so um now
speaking of action you have a very
interesting chemistry with mr. Vin
Diesel was there just a little part of
you that hoped you would get a chance to
use your safe word come plot in this
film
oh of course no I mean I think I think
that that he's I mean Xander's a popular
man she's got so many ladies after him
and he's he's a playboy I think she was
a tall order and an ambitious and
ambitious request on her part
her forgiving at the ecology tries every
day does the funny thing is she's
constantly I think her whole life she's
had her nose in a book and in her eyes
in front of a computer screen so when
faced with a person any kind of human
interaction she's not good at it nope
she's doing her best no yeah I have to
ask you
true or false will Damon ever be
reunited with his one true love as that
woman to the women told it wouldn't
allow I don't know no I was sorry about
Flatliners know where I am you tell me
about yeah I know Julia Roberts I wish I
was Julia Roberts can I come back as
Julia Roberts in my in my next life I
don't know there's new technology I'm
standing a lot standing around I I play
it it's a little different this film
there's three female leads Ellen Page
Kiersey Clemons and I are all the three
females whereas an original it was just
Julian four guys so just like the times
we're reflecting what's really happening
in the world and on-screen which I love
and so I there are parts of that story
alignment that are that I that are mine
as well but it's a little bit different
I'm excited about it though it's either
yeah keepers also yet we have a lot of
Canadians in this movie